فزت في جائزه الملك سلمان للتاريخ حول همم
الدور الشعر الشعبي او الشعر الشعبي في
تاريخ الدوله السعوديه تاريخ الدوله
السعوديه الاولى والثانيه من خلال الشعر
الشعبي والشعر العامي يمكن الدوله الثانيه
الناس تقول لك برز فيها شعراء معروفين
سواء من عيال الامراء الاعيان الباديه
والحاضره او من من بقيه فئات الناس لكن
الدوله الاولى كانه الشعر فيها نادر او
قليلت يعني يمكن هذا لبث الحديث اليوم
يعني نعم لا موجود فيها الدوله الاولى
تمتد من عام اا يعني اذا قلنا 24 همم
اماره الامام محمد
يعني الى عدد سقوطها 1818
وفي نصوص شعريه كثيره وفي انا اعطيك كمجمل
الان في من خلال البحث خرجنا تقريبا 25 85
الشاعر
و140 نص همم لها دلالات عظيمه في احداث
معينه اغفل عنها اغفلت من جانب الموثقين
في كتب التاريخ
وتؤيد بعض القرائن اللي وردت في المصادر
التاريخيه مثلا مثلا عندك همم قصيده همم
الامير مشاري بن عبد الرحمن في حصار
الدرعيه وفي تحديد همم
الفتره الزمنيه في حصار الدرعيه وفي
المقاومه المقاومه فيها الغذاء العثمانيين
في الدرعيه هذه مهمه لم يتطرق لها احد قبل
كده ولما تعطيك الدلاله هذه في النص وسنه
تناوله اذا كان همم
الامير عبد الرحمن مشاري بن عبد الرحمن
يقول يا ونتي ونت خلوج القطينه ونيتها
والناس ما هم دارين او النت اللي طوحت
بالحني كريم من يوم الركايب تجازين هنا
يذكر ايش ترحيل الاسره الى مصر نعم يومجله
عن دارهم منتحينا جل العذارى جضه تحرق
العين عن دارنا العوجا لمصر انجلينا
وعدونا لحقلنا والملاعين عن دارنا العوجا
دلاله لان الدرعيه وطلاق اسم العوجه يدل
على الدرعيه لا يدل على غيرها
وانهم تم اجلاهم الى مصر يا الله يا اللي
له الشدايد رجينا تجعل مطاليع الليالي على
الزين في الرجل من همه خفيه الونينه لانام
خال البال جريس صورتين عليك يا دارنا بعزك
مشينا مرضى العذارى لابسات السباهيين يا
دار ياما بك خزينه وجينا وما له المعادي
فوق
النظامين يا دار ذبحنا السمينه دلال
نعم
المهم يقول يا دار يا مال المجالس بنينا
ومنادم بين الرجال التجاريين يا دار ياما
بكن سر الخدين لما عزه تلهى دقبودا
المعادين يا دار يا ما نلطم العايلين
انثار بطراف قدام المعادين
فزعاتنا اللي مثل ورد القطينه لباسه
بالكون زين التوامين 200 يوم وزودهن 40
يعني 240 ايام الحصار ونحن نشوم العمر ما
نتبع الليل يعني صابرين على المقاومه
والدفاع باستفسار عن الدرعيه نار العميل
وظلوا المستحيله يعني اللي فيه همم تخلى
عنهم هذه الصراحه قصيده رائعه يمكن هذا
سبب بروز شخصيه الامير مشاري والقصيده
الشهيره اللي ارسلها خاله والامام تركي
ابو منهيه الذي رست درعيه رثت درعيه ايش
ابرز الدلالات من ابياتها مثلا اللي تشوف
العمراني
قال لها الوزير كان مقرب من الامام لكن
تتميز انها ذكرت النهضه العمرانيه والنهضه
التعليميه والنهضه الاقتصاديه التي كانت
تعيشها الدرعيه هل لك تطلعنا على نموذج من
هذا الامر الاشاره للنهضه العلميه وذكر
اسماء الاشخاص اللي من الاسره حلو برده في
نفس النص لكن القصيده يمكن همم
ولا تسوي قلت باسواقها اخر رقمها ولكن
عذرا كالغزال تليه ولا سامرت فيها جروب
الضيافهم ولا حاسبت فيها التجار بضيع ولا
حط فيها قبل هذا قيصريه ولا موسم فيها
العقول تضيع موسم التجاره
ولا مسجد